david it was an active scene earlier
here at the 7-eleven you're about to see
behind me on oakley boulevard and
western and while it's still unclear
what led up to the incident one man is
now dead
a deadly altercation at this 7-eleven on
oaky boulevard and western saturday
afternoon as a man and a woman pulled up
to this gas station convenience store
according to police once the couple
arrived the woman got out of the car and
went inside the store leaving the man
while she was inside the male boyfriend
appears to have gotten into an
altercation with an unhoused male
outside of the store that man had a
knife and stabbed the boyfriend it's
unclear what the argument was about but
soon after police say that's when the
girlfriend reacted after seeing what was
going on the female exit the store right
in the middle of this right as her
boyfriend is being stabbed she produces
a firearm and shoots the unhoused male
one time the unidentified victim a
28-year-old was shot and taken to umc
where he later died police say after
shooting the man the couple took off in
their car troopers soon found them on
the 15. the names of the people involved
have not been released but police say
the entire ordeal was captured on video
this 7-eleven had been blocked off for
hours while metro police investigated
but again the couple is in custody no
word on their charges reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now